might have your question is always the
same it's just I said tell me the story
of your life nobody is ever existed on
this planet and done something
successful by themselves
[Music]
rise and shine it's expresso time what's
up belief nation it's Evan I am sick but
I still believe in you and this channel
is still designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's start
your day off right together grab your
cup of tea and sip on today's message
create a great team
over to you Elon Musk also if you want
to know at Elon and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my to
54 confident series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below yeah there are
times when something is important enough
you've leave it enough that you do you
do it in spite of the fear
[Music]
you need a team around you to deliver a
lot of idea how do you choose your team
be somewhat well I suppose honestly that
it tends to be gut feel more than
anything else so when I interview
somebody that might have you questions
always the same it's just I said tell me
the story of your life and and the
decisions that you made a long way and
why you made them and also tell me about
some of the most difficult problems you
worked on and how you solved them and
that that question I think is very
important because the people that really
solve the problem they know exactly how
they solved it they know the little
details and the people that pretend it
to solve the problem
they can maybe go one level and then
they get stuck I've got a really special
bonus clip that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for
question of the day I want to know who
is the next person that you need to hire
on your team what is your job function
and just quick shadow to Christine and
Sam the husband wife duo who help edit
and make all these videos you guys are
awesome thank you for sticking with me
for all these years another great work
you do and for you guys watching let me
know who do you need to hire next put it
down in the comments below
nobody's ever done it by themselves so
the old the the entrepreneur that's
popular right now is the guy that works
from home
he's a solopreneur I don't know if you
have this term we have man yeah yeah
it's a complete misnomer nobody is ever
existed on this planet and done
something successful by themselves no
it's never happened so there's no
there's zero examples of anybody that's
done anything I mean Jesus had had 12
had 12 guys he was rolling with right
Alexander the Great had an army Genghis
Khan had had like you're not doing this
thing by yourself nobody does like for
too long I ran by myself and and it took
a lot of energy you know it took a lot
of energy it takes more energy running
by yourself
Ryan Seco here the captain the pilot and
and then the real estate dude he always
says dude it's just more fun to run with
the team and he's right yeah you know
Henry Ford people said Henry Ford made
the car out of his garage said yeah but
the company didn't make they didn't make
through the yeah yeah so a Mark
Zuckerberg so you know Facebook was made
out of a dorm Facebook was made when he
moved to Silicon Valley and start a
company a Steve Jobs Steven and the
other dude was it dude yeah yeah built
Apple you know supposedly built it out
of their garage yeah nobody knew about
Apple until he moved the company and
started in added employees so nobody's
doing anything great by themselves
here's what you got to do to build a
team
first of all number one you got to
realize no one ever did anything big
without an elite team around them Bill
Gates said he never did anything alone
except take tests he said he had Steve
Ballmer he had Paul Allen he had a
hundred thousand employees behind him to
build Microsoft and the biggest company
in the world same with Facebook the same
with Apple all same with Elon Musk that
realization will help you put in the
time and motivate you to have an effort
to want to put in the effort do you have
to train formally everybody knows they
need to train their employees but they
do it in a very informal haphazard way
which doesn't work what does formal
training look like well maybe a little
bit like a classroom a dedicated room
that your employees go into a dedicated
time pen and paper drills exercises
quizzes testing for retention
then number three you got to look over
their shoulder because once you do the
formal training
you can't expect memory retention to be
perfect so it must be continued over the
shoulder styled hope is that that you'll
take away the concept of a formal
training program most entrepreneurs
train very haphazardly they train only
in crisises well that's not going to cut
it if you only train during crisises and
guess what your blood pressure's going
to be through the roof and you're only
putting out fires prevent fires prevent
fire prevent fires so you should have at
least a three time a week training
program for your importance either
filling out one employee and it should
feel formal there should be a curriculum
tool there should be understanding when
they walk in the classroom or the
training room what they'll learn for
that day
there should be evaluations so don't
just be like most of the small business
owners that don't have an elite team
because they never took the time
they never understood the importance
they never formalized the training and
they never followed up on the track so
[Music]
the most important word ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
that would be like a little beacon if
you want to be the next Elon Musk check
out the video right next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
I could drop below a certain threshold
of sleep and although I'd be awake for
hours and I could sustain it I would get
less done because mental acuity would be
affected